rubble and mud all that's left behind
for many communities across Eastern
Afghanistan
the provinces of Madeon water dark and
rajni as well as the capital Kabul are
worst hits with dozens of people dead
six members of the family survived there
are no women left in the family they're
all gone there are three women in the
house
speed at which the floods hits during
the night surprised Minnie
it was 3 A.M when we woke up water was
coming into our house there was no way
out we waited for a while inside the
house and then my father decided that
we'd get out of the house to escape as
soon as we went outside we were caught
by the water and the water took everyone
my father and mother my wife my son and
my sister-in-law yeah
flooding is the latest disaster for
Afghanistan already suffering its third
consecutive year of droughts severe
economic hardship and the consequences
of Decades of War
a request from the government is that we
need serious assistance here we have a
lot of sick people in the village we
can't take them to the city right now
because our roads are blocked we have no
electricity they should help us to
rebuild the power supply and roads
in the past four months natural
disasters have killed and injured
hundreds of Afghans destroyed more than
3 000 homes and wiped out livestock and
farmland and as Afghans count the cost
of yet another disaster many are left
wondering if relief will ever come Alex
beard Al Jazeera